Oh
smile at my last book was a history of
Rockefeller Center which I didn't hear
the early part of the past decade and
the land the Rockefeller Center is built
on was during the 20s the heart of the
speakeasy belt in New York between 48
and 50 first street between fifth avenue
and sixth avenue there were 228
brownstones and they were largely
speakeasies flophouses whorehouses it
was really a lousy neighborhood and the
Rockefeller interests to assemble the
land they needed to acquire the ground
leases for each of these buildings and
so I did a lot of research in city
records and found the Rock father is
coming up against speakeasy owners who
had more political clout than they did I
said how did this happen which is the
best way to begin a brought a book sigh
that got me going and then I found
myself just in wandering in this
wonderland of this impossibly to
impossible to imagine period when in the
Constitution not just by law but in the
Constitution it said Americans couldn't
get liquor couldn't get alcoholic
beverages and you know there were only
two things in the Constitution that that
limit the rights of individuals rather
than the rights of government or the
powers of government the two things were
13th amendment you can't own slaves and
the 18th amendment you can't get liquor
pretty bizarre so that's at me going I
think it relates to where we are today
because of the notion of a divided
country and what prohibition was really
a stand-in issue there were people who
cared a great deal about prohibition and
they had reason to want liquor to be cut
back because the the rampant drunkenness
of the 19th century combined with the
fact that women have very few legal
rights did leave to a lot of women
particularly in children being horribly
damaged by the drunkenness that captured
so many of their husbands led to
bankruptcies have brought bringing home
disease ruined marriages in 1830 with is
of alcohol is triple what it is today so
imagine the the society we live in now
where the booze seems to be flowing
pretty freely and then multiply that by
three and you know even that and that
was on a per capita basis so there were
people who abstained so those who were
drinking really drank a great deal and
particularly in rural areas and then as
the immigrant populations came in in the
cities as well what it was other than
the concern about drinking was a as a
set of battle over the control of the
country and the prohibition was largely
they're not exclusively a movement that
came from the middle of the country
native-born white Protestants who feared
losing their country to the Irish the
Italians the Jews the Eastern Europeans
who were coming into the city so it was
a really intense divine which the stand
in issue could represent everything else
and I think we're going through exactly
the same thing now there's no question
that there are people who really don't
like obama's health care but they really
don't like the people who support
obama's health care and last year the
dividing issue could have been gay
marriage the few years before that or
constantly it's also abortion there
stand-in issues that represent a wide
wide range of issues and that was the
division that we had in this country
that led to prohibition
this extraordinary thing about
prohibition though there was a real
issue about alcohol consumption there
were three other issues that made
prohibition happen the women's suffrage
movement the income-tax movement and
World War one now one of these things
have to do with alcohol well this is the
peculiarities of the theater of politics
that things do not seem to be what they
are so the women's suffrage movement had
a lot to do with the fact that women had
no marital rights they didn't have
rights to divorce they didn't have
property rights they needed to be able
to express themselves for their own self
protection and they recognized that they
had kindred spirits in the
prohibitionist so it was really will
support you if you'll support us and the
women's Christian Temperance Union was
the engine the first engine that really
got the prohibition movement going then
it was realized by the people in the
prohibition movement we can't get rid of
alcohol without something to replace it
as a revenue producer because as much as
forty percent of federal revenue came
from the excise tax on liquor going back
to the whiskey rebellion of the 1790s so
you couldn't suddenly say no liquor no
wine no beer you wouldn't be able to run
a government any longer so they made
common cause done with the populace who
wanted an income tax and they passed the
income tax on them at the 16th amendment
in 1913 and only then did it become even
possible to seriously consider the
possibility of prohibition and then
World War one what does the world world
one have to do with prohibition well
while after Congress had enacted the
amendment and it had to be ratified by
three-quarters of the states during that
period World War one begins all the
Brewers have German names their names
are anheuser-busch Pabst Schlitz Rupert
Shaffer and on and on and on and it made
it possible for the prohibition forces
to demonize the Brewers as serving the
interests of the Kaiser when we were at
war with Germany and that's we'll put it
over the top so you get these three
things that have nothing to do with each
other and really nothing to do with the
issue at its center namely prohibition
making it possible for there to be not
just the law but a change in the damn
Constitution
well there was probably an increase in
crime he could argue that there was for
a period of not positive drinking did go
down and it remained down the level of
alcohol consumption in the u.s. did not
come back to pre-prohibition levels
until the 1970s in fact we're a little
bit lower than the 1970s now so if you
think that there's too much drinking it
did have a positive effect in that sense
criminal behavior on a large scale of
course was rampant every time somebody
acquired a drink every time he bought a
drink removed liquor from one place to
another you were breaking the law it is
also true that the criminal syndicates
the the national criminal syndicate was
entirely a product of prohibition until
then the in each city you might have a
criminal element a criminal gang that
controlled vice of all sorts
prostitution gambling drugs but there
was no reason for them to stretch beyond
the limits of their own neighborhoods as
it were or their cities once you had to
move great quantities of alcohol from
one place to another you needed
cooperation so the mobs and various
cities got together there was the famous
conference in Atlantic City in 1929 the
sort of peace conference in which they
divided up the country and was once and
to get that agreed not to poach on each
other's territory without prohibition
there's no reason to do that so yeah a
lot of increase in crime on the other
hand the image that we have of the 20s
is this area of lawlessness machine guns
are was known as the Chicago typewriter
right that depth at that the submachine
gun the people there were exceptions
obviously but it was get it was criminal
on criminal warfare there were not a lot
of innocent bystanders who were hurt by
that kind of violence
what's comparable what's interesting to
me about the comparison to the drug
trade today is there is a human appetite
that drugs is are satisfying there's a
human appetite liquor satisfied and it
appears to be the case I think it's
indisputable that people are going to
get their drugs or their liquor whether
or not it's against the law the
consequence of the limitation on earth
of illegal limitation on it is that the
federal government the government gets
no tax revenue from it and it's unable
to regulate it effectively so peculiarly
it was easier to get a drink during
Prohibition when it was against the law
than it was after prohibition when it
was legal during Prohibition there was
no regulatory system of any kind it was
simply against the law after prohibition
you had age limits you had to be 18 or
21 you couldn't be open a liquor stores
couldn't be open on Sundays you couldn't
be near at church there were closing
hours there was an entire superstructure
of laws that made it possible to control
drinking and to bring it a great deal of
revenue franklin roosevelt in october of
1932 he gave a speech in newark and when
she said if we brought back beer alone
that would be a quarter of a billion
dollars into the US treasury in one year
and it was so the notion that we are
right now seeing a similar illegal
substance that is nonetheless desired
being traded in huge quantities by
criminal syndicates the notion that that
could be something that's regulated made
safer and provide revenue for the
government makes it a very peel
appealing argument for legalization